As I said earlier the Gang of Four book was immensely popular and
has spawned a whole, a whole movement within the software development community.
However, patterns are not without problems and
I want to look a few of them here. These come from Czenecki and
Eisenhecker book which is listed on my class resources page. First off,
patterns are primarily implemented using, using two standard
object-oriented compo, compo, composition mechanisms, inherit inheritance and
object composition. But using patterns can add complexity. Often,
there's the introduction of extra objects and extra levels of indirection. So
your code becomes more complicated even though you're using standard techniques.